[Applaudissements]
je vais expliquer aux téléspectateurs
qui n'étaient pas avec nous ce soir hier
soir jeudi de rentrer chez lui en fait
la part belle à passer la nuit ici à
nous attendre à suc'et de ce petit plus
alors on va les voir aller chercher
thierry moreau ça peut vous venez venez
venez venez mobileye ou moraux il est
oui a validé la à la la la la la la il
est pas bien il est pas bien alors il
est pas bien il n'est pas bien qu'est ce
qui se passe mon bébé qu'est ce qui se
passe j'ai pas pu rentrer y avait les
vigiles qui m'ont empêché de revenir tu
peux revenir je t'ai dit s'aplanir tu
peux venir
vous pouvez laisser rentrer si vous
regardez moi ça va au delà il a deux
bouteilles dévoile avec moi c'est vrai
là il lui faut un beau bébé français
allait présenter les autres chroniqueurs
ya qui après vous jarno de arnaud arnaud
[Applaudissements]
côté guyane et de ramallah gré drame à
la grève samedi et à côté des nouragues
a dit jean-luc évidemment pour les 4
pièces
retour vont amener les tueries bon
gardien
[Applaudissements]
allah